uh up first this is chase and breedwell
and nick longbottom
from cincinnati longbottom from
[Music]
cincinnati
hit them sub son watch this
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
dang
a sound perm boy
that's some that's when that jock jams
is just stylish you know what i'm saying
wow look at that fur by the front baby
look at that candy apple inside dude
damn bro
this guy is super swaggy oh
king king king i don't know where you
can get those two 12 inch subs anymore
well
those are 12s i think those yeah those
those are they call them 12 son 12.
that's a big
yeah twelve thousands dude you see that
you see how much shake was in that thing
this is that johnny neutron son more
shake than a [ __ ] head a jamba juice
dude this guy's got everybody's got
motor oil in his mustache dude
i got a new fave this guy is my fave
this guy all sucks start a [ __ ]
uh honda civic bro this guy ain't joking
right here
decent man decent american man here well
yeah brendan now i got a i got a few
questions i'd like to see the outside i
think he's put
all his money into the speakers inside i
gotta be honest i don't think this is a
car i think this is almost just like a
little space in the yard or in a
i don't think so autobot things yeah i
think it's almost just like a weed
station because if you look at this bar
that we see right here on the top
left that red bar just even you don't
have to play the video right there
yeah that's some sort of um it looks
like it's supporting the speakers
oh it could be some sort of special
hovel where this guy really has some
decent sound because back in the day
gangsters used to have the boom boom
boom
the 12. you could buy base uh hits i
forget
i think it's called base hits and you're
going to date an underage girl and
you're going to not move away from town
if you have this system
yeah yeah you'll be drinking mike's hard
lemonade and driving around town sad
you're going to be making mike's hard
lemonade dude all over town
yeah mike's going to hire you to make a
plan yeah you're never going to leave
town you're going to get your ass beat
by a lot of
local dads bro if you have
this sound system it should actually be
in that section of the store
hey you want to get your ass beat by a
local parent
buy these 12.
shout out this guy i don't know where
you get that done these days that's why
i used to do it
a place called shaq city used to do it
in my hood and let's go to the culture
corner because this is something that's
hot in asian culture
and black yeah so what do we know of an
asian black thing
chin you had speakers in your car i did
yeah you did it [ __ ] yeah you did wow
big time huh
what did you have twelves
daddy damn that's 27 worth bro
fast and furious chin over here
ludacris you have a race for pink slips
chin
no because my car was really slow
because you had so many goddamn speakers
in it or all your friends were in it
you live your life one quarter mile at a
time bro amen brother
[Music]
is